but i think that's an incredibly
relevant question and i think doj in the
same way that it is uh setting up a task
force to investigate oligarchs should
look into people who are russian
propagandists and shilling for putin
that's being if you are a foreign asset
to a dictator it should be investigated
in fact i remember
when tulsi gabbard and i even hate that
we're discussing it because i think to
myself who is this woman she's a you
know she's no longer in congress she's a
failed presidential candidate she only
practically exists on twitter and the
fact that we're giving her oxygen is
what makes her relevant that we're
talking about her on her topic they used
to arrest people for doing stuff like
this if they thought you were
colluding with the russian agent if they
thought you were putting out information
or taking information and handing over
to russia they used to actually
investigate stuff like this and i guess
now you know there seems to be no bars
what are you two crazy [ __ ] talking
about
what are you talking about you want to
arrest people who are different than you
politically tulsi gabbard she's a member
of our military she's a former
congresswoman a democrat you just don't
like her so you want to arrest her you
ought to arrest tucker carlson the very
dapper tucker carlson
what are you saying you you guys are
nuts you're just not i only agreed to do
this show because i thought that whoopi
whoopie was sane she was good sister
sister act two
anna's just nuts i don't even know what
she's doing here the other ones are
racist the the there's the drunk one
what is what are we all doing here
you people are everything that you've
come to hate you know that
uh
why am i here
i need a haircut
okay that's better